[Music]
while Western media creates middle-age
superheroes with a few exceptions anime
primarily celebrates the youth by giving
them various motivations goals and
tremendous power one of the things that
anime can do is create these idealized
humans for us to look up to while
growing up especially during our teenage
years that's something that we all
really needed characters of our age that
we could look up to that are trying
their best often to reach goals that are
in their distant future and seem
impossible so today we'll be looking at
these badass teenagers in anime while no
one on this list is really perfect in
every possible way they're trying their
hardest in their own scenarios primarily
through effort and their grit to come
out on top
we start off this list with Ichigo from
Bleach of all the characters on this
list Ichigo Kurosaki's perhaps one of
the most stubborn and hot-headed
throughout the series he didn't back
down from fighting opponents that seemed
too challenging for him his reluctance
to quit even when facing opponents more
skilled than him is evident when he
faced the captains of the Court guard
squad he refused to quit even egging on
his opponents despite the odds he
eventually reached a place of power
where he overcame those odds Ichigo has
various skills like enhance strength
speed and reflexes but according to both
Aizen and Arikara
his most astounding ability is his
growth rate he grasped the basic control
of his advanced techniques in days where
it would normally take several years for
even the most gifted Shinigami
next on the list its Kagura from Gintama
Kagura is super strong and doesn't rely
on men for anything she isn't in the
plot to be a love or conflict of
interest for any other character and she
remains useful for the entire series she
comes from the yato clan which means she
has super strength but unlike others in
her clan she's somewhat of a pacifist
while the rest relish fighting her
peaceful nature keeps her from going
full instinct on her enemies all the
time except for the one time her yeah
though nature overcame her in the fight
against a butoh which was terrifyingly
awesome
next up its can connect eat from Tokyo
ghoul connect ease someone who's
traumatic experiences morphed him from a
wimp into a stoic badass this is
something called post-traumatic growth
the idea that what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger connect II
embodies that becoming one of the
greatest goals facing tough situations
overcoming them and becoming someone who
people want to follow kaneki's a complex
and intriguing character his
transformation from a wimp to one of the
most badass characters of a show makes
him a deserving entry on this list
[Music]
Malka new crew
[Music]
Scottie you
[Music]
next on the list we have Arzo from fairy
tale as ours a badass teenager the fact
that she's a teenager is something you
would never guess judging by how
composed strong and smart years
she's an s-class mage which is the
highest ranking a mage can get in a
guild with the exception of a guild
master our Azaz magic is something that
most girls would be jealous of the
ability to have a magical wardrobe with
a seemingly endless option of outfits
which you can change into instantly and
unlike the rest of us who can only feel
a bit better and more confident in a
fresh outfit our czars outfits massively
enhance their abilities bring a whole
new meaning on the Power Suit concept
next we have Luffy from one piece before
Johnny Depp and the Pirates of the
Caribbean made pirates cool and lovable
Eiichiro Oda recognized the charm and
appeal of being a pirate being free not
obeying anyone's rule traveling the
world exploring and adventuring with
your comrades the embodiment of this
idea is Luffy roofies the man striving
to be the freest in the world because if
a pirate someone who represents freedom
then the pirate king is the freest man
in the world one who doesn't have to
abide by anyone's rules or have any
constraints the man striving to be the
Pirate King since he was a kid the man
whose friends have absolute trust in if
Luffy isn't a badass team then who is
[Applause]
next on the list we have Mikasa from
attack on Titan regarded as a soldier
who's worth a hundred men by her
superiors because is easily one of the
strongest non Titan characters in the
series she can take down a Titan ten
times her size
simply put she's a total badass due to
the death and despair that she's been
through throughout her life she has a
cold personality she gets criticized a
lot by the fanbase for being
overprotective of Eren but we need to
keep in mind he's the only family she's
got left it's hard not to get invested
in Mikasa is unsettling past and her
uncanny abilities as a soldier make her
one of attack on Titan standout
characters
[Music]
number four we have a more Gianna from
Maggie
more Gianna is a full-blooded finalist a
hunting tribe that's often considered
the strongest race in the world she's uh
sir if Elsa watched a bunch of Dragon
Ball Z and Bruce Lee movies
she's an ass-kicking machine with fierce
determination and strength yes still has
a feminine nature even though she's very
awesome she still suffers from an
inferiority complex this probably comes
from being a slave since she was a child
which teaches us all not to allow our
past experiences to shape the way we
look at ourselves because we might just
be more badass than we think
great
mom wake up
moving on to number three it's Naruto
from Naruto Naruto is probably one of
the most inspirational characters in
anime he has the powerful spirit of the
nine tailed beasts within him which he
later learns to control and coincide
with as it allows him to become one of
the most powerful ninjas alive even
after enduring a tough childhood he
still came out positive and cheerful as
ever he went through so many struggles
alone from such a young age dealing with
all the hate emanating from the villages
that was directed towards him even
through this he's able to treasure
everyone he loves and has the strength
and determination to protect and save
them no matter what he just never gives
up whatever the situation and that's
what makes him one of the legends in
anime
[Music]
at number two its kilowatt from Hunter
hunter a lot of kids have to deal with
the high expectations their parents set
for them some parents want their kids to
be doctors lawyers or even presidents
but kilowatt had it tough with his
family pushing on him the idea of
becoming a world-class assassin with
such a harsh upbringing quinoa was
always a tough little edge Lord he has
strength skills and good instincts and
on top of that he has electricity like
nen powers this allows kilowatt to be
incredibly fast which makes him an
intensely dangerous character to fight a
senior mejor de team immunise workout of
it
Oh salute and finally at number one we
have Jotaro from JoJo's bizarre
adventures Stardust Crusaders
Jotaro is the third Jojo we meet known
for his pissed off and stoic personality
he travelled towards Egypt to save his
mother while spending some time relaxing
and enjoying his favorite hobby of
kicking assassin asses his stand star
platinum has the incredibly creative
ability to kick ass real fast and real
hard it boasts phenomenal speed as we
saw it intercept a bullet from
point-blank range and is stated to
exceed the speed of light but overall
there's only a few teenagers who could
beat him in a battle of wits or
badassery he is indeed the most badass
teenager in anime school Bill's shoe
shoulders
[Music]
well that's the list of the most badass
teens in anime do you have your own
favorite badass team let me know down
below in the comment section and don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
the channel and hit the bell
notification so you'll be updated
whenever new videos are published until
next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]